rachelle willenski she is now admitting
that there is a difference between
hospitalization from covidin with cobit
so many people were pointing this out
last year that every time somebody died
the question should have been whether
they died from covet or with covid
because if you were 90 years old and you
had leukemia and then you died and you
had covey because they tested you did
you die because of the covet or did you
die because of the leukemia and it
happens that you had coveted at the time
and we were told you're not even allowed
to ask these questions well now that the
cases have spiked there are a lot of
people in the hospital particularly
children who are in the hospital not
from covid but with covert there are a
lot of kids who are going to the
hospital with say flu or rsv and then
they're also testing positive for covid
which means they're not there because of
the cobit rachelle lenski was asked
about this he says oh yeah we're
gathering stats on that now weird that
you guys didn't bother gathering stats
on this over at the cdc over the course
of the last two years
do you know how many of the 836 000
deaths in the u.s linked to covet are
from covid or how many are with covet
but they had other comorbidities do you
have that breakdown
um yes of course with omicron we're
following that very carefully our death
registry of course um takes a few weeks
to
and it takes a few weeks to collect and
of course omicron has just been with us
for a few weeks but those data will be
forthcoming
oh this data will be fourth i'm glad
that you're collecting them now weird
that you haven't collected them over the
course of the last two years and when
you realize what it is that the cdc has
actually spent money investigating and
what they have not spent money doing or
investigating it really is incredible so
we've had all sorts of studies from the
cdc about racial disparities in
treatment of covet but how many studies
have we had about the actual level of
antibodies in the general population
early on
like how many people do have actually
had kova do we even know that why wasn't
the cdc doing any of that why was it
left to private people in like santa
clara county organizing private studies
as to exactly how many people had gotten
covered
well how about the cdc stats and how
many people have gotten this via
transmission on airplanes the cdc has
provided no data like the most practical
aspects of this virus the cdc has
ignored the entire time instead pursuing
specifically political questions and now
that the politics of code have shifted
against the lockdown fanatics now all of
a sudden they're like you know what
maybe we should check out how many
people died of kovid versus with kovit
it is incredible how much our public
health establishment has blown itself
out the story of the last decade in
american politics is every major
institution in american society
destroying its own credibility on the
shoals of politics it really is
unbelievable everything from the ama to
the educational institutions of our
nation
to the cdc like every single area
that of institutional trust has been
decayed not by skeptics from the outside
but by people from the inside who in
order to fight those skeptics have
completely undermined
all of their credibility and trust it's
it's absolutely insane by the way
rachelle willenski admitted over the
weekend the killer app when it comes to
the joe biden vax mandate if the vax
does not prevent transmission there's no
reason for a vax mandate
and the entire basis for a vaccinate is
that you have to keep the unvaxxed away
because the unvacs can infect the vax or
something or they can infect each other
you don't want that happening at work
and that is the entire basis of the vax
mandate but if the vaccinate if the
vaccinated can also pass covid that is
completely irrelevant well here was for
shoveling last night admitting that the
vaccines don't actually stop
transmission which of course we all knew
since all of our friends are getting
covered no matter how many times they've
been vast
um our vaccines are working
exceptionally well they continue to work
well for delta with regard to severe
illness and death they prevent it but
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission so if you're going home to
somebody who has not been vaccinated to
somebody who can't get vaccinated
somebody who might be immunosuppressed
or a little bit fail
frail somebody who has
comorbidities that put them at high risk
i would suggest you wear a mask in
public indoor settings
okay so forever presumably because
omicron is now an epidemic i mean
it is now endemic rather omicron's
everywhere so presumably for the rest of
your life it's just going to be a risk
that is out there so i mean they it
they've gone completely crazy i mean i
have a 98 year old grandmother and my 98
year old grandmother is uh is in a
facility an assisted living facility
she's she's older and um and they have
locked her in her room like full-on
locked her in her room it doesn't matter
that she's been exposed to coveted 25
times over they've now locked her in her
room even though she is is not
immuno-suppressed like at a certain
point you're just gonna have to let
people live because this is what it is
that is the end of the story at least
people should be given the choice as to
whether or not they are allowed to see
other people
it's it's totally crazy at this point i
mean even brian stelter is mocking the
cdc there's brian stelter over at cnn
going oh wait a second the cdc is bad at
its job so all the i thought this was
questioning the science i thought that
if you mocked the cdc or made fun of
anything the cdc says this is
questioning the science apparently
you're allowed to do so now so it's open
season on all the institutions that we
were banned from even criticizing on
social media for the last year and a
half
here's the today show here's savannah
guthrie interviewing the cdc director
being very much in touch with the public
recognizing the cdc has turned into a
punchline it is so sad but it's true the
cdc has turned into a punchline watch
all of this mixed messages or new
messages has led to a meme on social
media poking fun at the cdc's advice
tweets like cdc now recommends eating
straight off the floor at waffle house
the cdc now says it's in fact okay to
eat tide pods the cdc says go ahead and
get bangs you know it's amusing people
letting off steam's steam of course but
is there a larger credibility problem
with your agency right now
and the answer is yes there's a huge
credibility crisis
i don't know when tucker carlson
inhabited the body of potato brian
stelter but apparently that's a thing
now by the way cnn is now reporting that
richarlinsky who's been terrible at this
since the get-go
and many of us have been criticizing her
for being terrible at this since the
gecko rochelle willenski apparently is
now in media training like she literally
has to have people come in and explain
to her how to do media hits which is
kind of incredible for somebody who's
the head of the cdc
cnn has learned dr wolenski is in media
training for months she's been meeting
with a consultant to improve
communication skills the well-regarded
infectious disease expert had no
government experience before president
biden appointed her and has often seemed
out of step with the white house and dr
fauci leading to some abrupt and
confusing changes in guidance now
walensky's under fire for not following
the cdc's own playbook for explaining
new guidance a biden covet advisor tells
me the cdc has got to do a better job
communicating what they're doing and why
and that has to happen quickly
okay my favorite thing here is the
president of the united states being the
cdc they're really bad at coms
that's joe biden's white house
joe biden is not even alive
his comms consists of him stumbling out
to a podium saying several sentences in
a row that seem to take the form of
sentences but don't actually have words
that make sense in them sort of like a
lewis carroll parody of grammar and then
stumbling off the stage before taking
any questions he's like we need to get
michelle olinski some media
mechanimization
man you know you've blown it when joe
biden is recommending you get some media
training
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content